los llamados de la población parecen
haber sido escuchados Después de tres
años china estaría encaminado al final
de su política covid cero la cual ha
causado estrictas restricciones
sanitarias y unas protestas sin
precedentes por lo que el gobierno
levantó parcialmente sus medidas
restrictivas este 7 de diciembre las
personas contagiadas con el virus debían
realizar su aislamiento en centros de
cuarentena ahora los casos menos graves
podrán hacerlo desde casa de igual
manera se reduce la frecuencia de las
pruebas pcr el país entra en una nueva
etapa
ya no será necesario el uso del código
sanitario y las pruebas pcr salvo para
acceder a residencias de mayores
hospitales colegios y otros lugares
específicos
[Música]
un cambio radical respecto a la política
serocovic implementada en los últimos
tres años que alivia a la población
nuestra vida y nuestro trabajo van a ser
más fáciles ahora porque ya no
necesitamos pruebas negativas de covid
para ingresar a los edificios de
oficinas esto significa que podemos
reducir drásticamente la cantidad de
pruebas que se realizan eso está bien
Nos ahorra tiempo
creo que las personas pueden cuidarse
solas mire a pesar de la relajación de
las medidas de covid las personas
todavía usan máscaras y se protegen
cuando salen
ahora será posible viajar de una
provincia a otra sin tener que presentar
una prueba pcr negativa con menos de 48
horas estos anuncios llegan pocas horas
después de la publicación oficial de
nuevas cifras preocupantes para la
segunda economía más grande del mundo
las exportaciones chinas se desplomaron
en noviembre bajo el efecto combinado de
su política covid cero y una caída de la
demanda